we got huddle stuff is that the don't do
it today we're doing something quite
interesting Mason was like hey why don't
we why don't we rent a red and go make
some videos I said that'd be great let's
do a blogging 10k because that's
completely not supported by anywhere
near time yes it's not the time the
sensor is like like sixteen by nine
right at Yale for thirty-five Spencer so
anamorphic the way it works is it
actually shoots follow and then it
stretches it out later so we can I'll
show you the two different mode : to
this 8k when it stretches at advocate
started from the bottom now we're here
remember the ruffles cams like this that
like little thing and you like have an
USB I will never forget because that was
one of my favorite cameras ever I
actually just did a recent backups of
all of my old videos so well maybe I'll
find a little flip cam footage to put in
right after this Drive you know why I'm
right now the underwater tape cute video
anyway so this is the action mount if
you want to strap this to motorcycle or
to window on your car I plot would be a
black camel I give this a sort of retro
[Music]
I bought myself a gift hey I bought
myself a gift a fidget spinner
so did you get to at home yep
[Music]
with it
when you were a little
[Music]
oh I love fun supernatural super slow-mo
it's what I like maybe a little less
aggressive am I too aggressive with my
hair flip your are they cool I'm so
excited to see this footage so basically
you're going to be slaw once in 4k and
then in whatever came and I may be hit
on that yeah on my channel you can put
in can give me and my animals doing that
standing my heart thank you blood I'm
super excited and someday I'm going to
be looking back on this and be like you
remember when we vote for birthday cake
law another reason it's not an actual
vlog is did you get this before man
writes true I do have to try to get a
picture of me trying to pull back and
draw with it it's cute it lightens alone
is mouthing what that lens Nathan how
much is it what is it oh it's a lo mo a
35-millimeter loma anamorphic someone I
can name like what year I just need if
older than me
what 82 it's older than me hmm I'm sure
Trump love that one oh yeah we're off to
get ice cream my goodness charcoal ice
cream exact I have realized Zoo I'm or
livestream why what dude what is this
charcoal is this like you're eating a
charcoal briquette like we're not sure
we're going to find out that's why I was
always exclusive does it help your acne
if you have acne the charcoal make it go
away
too many questions first reach areas
please on your dash
it'll be em man downtown is freaking
loud what is this
turns me off
I'm going up the Muslim so I know that
your line right
that's before
I know that you like four feet I have to
go all the way to like there get really
close have to go to there try turning a
website
they're ridiculous
[Music]
oh my gosh is no
- after to me we're going no we're not
going downtown we're going doesn't
thirst you're crawling on and I'm
supposed to have my keys to my car oh
I'm not sure I think uh you know um
another man's trash is another man's
come-up I'm still filming home gone
a day you know cinematographer from a
bodybuilder is it heavy it's so heavy
and holding it's like a person holding
it like a cat it's like at 30
[Music]
Lichter
yeah probably the lighter one we had a
really fun day today I'm so excited you
work on this fun little project you guys
will probably see it in a while I don't
know how long it would take to edit and
go through footage and Nathan could be
doing some color correcting are you
excited making you fun it was so cool it
was great or for those toys I had fun
not much
flip it I'll see you guys later and stay
tuned for us stay tuned for the actual
feature film which is not a feature film
it's a feature film a k9k vlog
[Music]
you